you grew up then in where in Ghana hello
Jonna like I spent my time between Ghana
in Detroit lot but like when I was in
Ghana I lived in a city called Accra
Ghana this is a the capital of Ghana mhm
believe me yeah weird trust you yeah
yeah no you can look it up it's so
describe growing up in God that a and
and and you're like any other kid I mean
what do you watch on TV and Ghana well
like as a kid like I would be I would
watch movies a lot and I would always
like go to this place called Ravel video
club it's like right down the road from
my house so I like walk there and I've
always like rent the exact same movies
like I would always rent like police
academy and I'd watch it and like this
is brilliant and then like I remember I
like now it's the Simpsons joke but I
like watched it and I was like you know
what I think I should be a police
officer when I grow up you wanted to be
a police arts because you watch police
academy like just seem like so much fun
and like hiding semantics right get all
those sounds yeah I want to go into
sound effect police work that'd be great
if you had taken the exam to be a police
officer like when do we get to make the
sound effects
you